SPEAKER 1: Moving from
on-prem to the cloud
can bring a ton
of nifty features
for your company
and applications.
But one of the biggest
challenges, and certainly
the scariest, is how this
movement can potentially
expose your systems to
new vulnerabilities.
And without taking
the right precautions,
you can run into the risk
of exposing your system
in very problematic ways.
So in this episode,
I'll be covering
how to control your traffic
in and out of your instances
on GCP by creating firewall
rules once you establish
hybrid connectivity
to Google Cloud.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Firewall rules are extremely
important for a number
of reasons.
They allow you to isolate your
internal network and instances
from unwanted access.
They allow you to monitor
inbound and outbound activity
coming from your network
for suspicious activity,
blocking items that are
considered dangerous based
on a set of security rules.
They establish the
first line of defense
against attacks,
viruses, and malware,
and helps create
a secure network.
So let's take a look at
firewalls more closely.
In traditional on-prem
systems, multiple servers
on a single internal
network are supported
through the use of a
cluster of firewalls
coupled with a load balancer.
A large drawback of this
traditional architecture
is that it doesn't scale well.
In an on-prem environment,
a firewall is generally
a dedicated piece
of hardware that
has an upper limit
in terms of capacity,
and this makes a
firewall a choke point.
To support dynamic
scaling, you'll
need to habitually run
down to the server room
and replace the
hardware with ones
that can handle increased load.
Of course, this creates
its own challenge.
When the traffic
goes back to normal,
you've now got a big piece
of expensive hardware going
unused.
This is where Google Cloud
platform's distributed
firewalls can make a difference.
Google's global network
has a federation
of firewalls that
can operate and scale
as your systems need them.
So you only end up
paying for what you use
rather than making commitments
for long-term expectations.
This gives you the same power of
your on-site perimeter network,
which blocks all incoming
traffic by default,
but allows you to scale
without lifting a finger.
Now here's the important part.
Each VPC network functions
as a distributed firewall.
If you want info on
setting up the VPC,
check out the first episode.
A distributed firewall
means that, by default, it
will handle filtering traffic.
But you need to adjust it
to handle your access needs,
like applying firewall
rules to tagged instances.
In this example, when a request
comes in from a Compute Engine
System labeled with
the red tag, it
hits the applicable
firewall rule
before being allowed to
communicate with the blue tag.
While firewall rules are
defined at the network level,
connections are allowed or
denied on a per-instance basis.
You can think of the
GCP firewall rules
as existing not only
between your instances
and other networks, but
between individual instances
within the same network.
In Google Cloud, a firewall
rule is made up of four things--
an action either to
allow or deny traffic.
That is, a rule can either
allow incoming, ingress,
or outgoing, egress, traffic,
but not both simultaneously;
the type of protocol
to which it applies,
such as TCP, UDP, and
ICMP; either a source
or a destination for
which the rule applies.
This cannot be both as it
depends on the direction
of the firewall you create.
For example, for
ingress rules you
would specify the source,
which can be IP ranges, tags,
or service accounts,
or a combination.
You wouldn't specify
a destination
because the rule
is already being
applied to a specific
VM's inbound traffic.
You can specify the ports
on ingress or egress rules.
For example, allowing ingress
TCP traffic on port 22
to allow for SSH access.
You can also deny a
VM's egress TCP traffic
on all ports for all
destination VMs in an IP range.
Each of these parameters
means that firewall rules
can help control traffic to
and from your Google Cloud VMs
accordingly.
Let's look at what
this looks like.
I have two existing
servers here that
are trying to use iPerf
to test network speed.
Here are my two SSH
sessions with these VMs
with iPerf setup.
But note that I have to
use a specific port for it,
and since that's not part of
the standard firewall rules,
it doesn't work.
The only default
firewall rules created
are allow egress and deny
ingress traffic, and for Linux
instances, allow SSH/TCP
traffic on port 22.
We're going to create a
new firewall rule that
allows access for iPerf.
Go to the VPC Network tab
and click Firewall Rules.
You can see there are a bunch of
default firewall rules created
for the default network.
We need to create one
for our custom VPC
that our instances
are sitting in.
So click Add Firewall Rule.
Create a rule iPerf access.
Change the network to VPC 1.
Leave it as Ingress
and change it to Allow.
The target tag will
be iPerf access.
Source IP range will
be the public internet.
The protocol will be TCP and
port will be 5001 to run iPerf.
Once that saves, go back
to the VM Instances page
and add the iPerf access
tag to Instance 1.
And I'll do the same
now for Instance 2.
Let's run iPerf again.
And boom, it's working.
Firewalls are an
extremely important part
of your on-prem-to-cloud
transition.
They're the basis
at which traffic
can flow to and from
individual cloud instances,
but also to and from
your on-premise network
to your cloud network.
If you want to learn about
more complex use cases,
check out the
documentation linked below.
But to get you moving on your
migration to Google Cloud,
stay tuned for the next
episode on configuring IPs.
And remember,
optimizing your network
means freeing up your bandwidth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]